Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Da bin ich wieder.
Oh, Windows hat irgendwas am Sound verstellt.
Sekunde.
Ein Overlays-Weg.
So.
Nee, immer noch.
Windows, was machst du da?
So.
Jetzt.
Jetzt besser.
Okay, keine Ahnung, warum das immer der Fall ist bei Windows.
Man weiß es nicht.
Aber ich meine, es ist Windows-Logik.
Das muss man nicht verstehen.
Recommend time.
So, ich kann mal wieder ein bisschen aufwachen.
Wobei, ist nicht, dass ich gepennt hätte oder so.
Ich war gerade 45 Minuten rennen.
und laut garmin ist mein wii o2 max bisschen gesunken obwohl ich eigentlich
so viel renne wie immer keine ahnung warum der sinkt aber ich würde mich da
mal nicht so viel rein interpretieren was zur ursache
wir programmieren ein bisschen rast oder ein bisschen weiter ist ja nicht so als
er schon viel gemacht und gucken uns mal an wie man ordentliches error handling
macht unser ziel ist immer noch ein usb gerät auslesen also so mit vom device
quasi beiz vom device und da kann es natürlich auch fehler geben zum beispiel
wenn einer das gerät abzieht oder wenn man keine permissions hat drauf
zuzugreifen oder wenn das ding irgendwelche fehler hat beim lesen oder
keine ahnung ja das muss man mal gucken wie das wie das wir mal schauen wie man
das am besten machen weil wir müssen ja auch die die daten die von dem usb gerät
kommen halbwegs sind nicht passen mal schauen wie wir das machen
mark google
Aha, Logitech ist an.
Sehr gut.
Exzellent.
Werbung?
Tja, kann man leider nichts machen.
Das Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist...
Oder, oder U-Blog Origin.
Wobei U-Blog Origin auch nicht mehr so wirklich bei allem hilft, seitdem die Webseitenbetreiber auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen sind und haben gesagt, ey, weißt du was?
Wir liefern den Content aus von den gleichen Servern und quasi exakt gleich wie die Videos.
wir liefern die Werbung so aus wie den Content,
dann ist es natürlich schwierig, Werbung und Content
auseinanderzuhalten. U-Block Origin
ist noch,
also generell im Browser Adblocker,
ist noch das einzige, was halbwegs
hilft, weil die können den Content der Seite lesen.
Was überhaupt nicht mehr
hilft, deswegen verstehe ich auch immer nicht diese ganzen
Videos, die es immer noch auf YouTube gibt,
von wegen,
wie heißt dieses Ding, Piehole
und
Adblock
home und so bei edgard home macht überhaupt also ein bisschen macht die
werbung vielleicht weg auf irgendwelche newsseiten oder so aber bei den meisten
sachen hilft das überhaupt nichts mehr wenn letztendlich ist es ein dns adblocker
ja und ein dns adblocker kann also allein schon als prinzip bedingt ja kann
ein dns adblocker nicht ads blocken und content der quasi vom gleichen server
kommt das ist für einen dns adblocker nicht zu unterscheiden ist ja logisch ja
also wenn die von cdn punkt youtube punkt keck w sowohl content als auch
werbung schicken hast du keine chance das war früher deutlich einfacher da war
das recht gut erkennbar warum dennster peep oder eigentlich noch da war das
recht gut erkennbar von von welchem ende jetzt werbung kommt und von was von
von welchem Endpunkt Werbung kommt, von welchem Endpunkt
irgendwie Content kommt.
Aber das kannst du halt mittlerweile nicht mehr so richtig erstellen.
Steiner hat ja Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge.
Subscriber!
So, wir machen nochmal Updates.
Weil wir haben erst heute Morgen ein Update gemacht.
Und ihr wisst, wie das ist. Arch Linux
By the way.
Siehste? Siehste?
Heute Morgen Update gemacht.
beim gleich wieder 700 mb updates so mag ich das was muss alles schön
bleeding edge sein hier gibt es nichts neues
was ddc ddc hotel war ich weiß nicht was das ist was ist das habe ich nie gehört
control monitor setting using ddc cn usb was was was was soll das sein wird gerade
bei mir geupdatet okay das macht aber nichts wird die anzeige direkt raus an den open source
Was soll das sein?
Monitor Settings.
Such as brightness, color levels and input connector.
Moment, da kann man...
Moment, man kann da seinen Monitor...
Man kann Settings an den Monitor umstellen.
Damit?
Nee, oder?
Nee, da braucht der Monitor einen extra...
Guck mal, die...
Die Playlist mag ich nicht, die ist so unterschiedlich laut.
Das sagt...
Oh, shit.
Mein Browser ist am abkacken.
Damit kann ich?
Wie geht das jetzt?
No command specified.
Ja, okay, nice.
Sehen die neuen Man-Pages nicht
exquisite aus?
Detect.
Okay.
Oh, guck mal, der detectet eine Endlosschleife.
This monitor does not support DDCCI.
Okay.
Meine Capture Card kann das nicht.
Hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert.
Ja, das geht hier.
Display.
Ich glaube, Brightness geht, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Was tatsächlich echt schwierig ist, ist Color Profiles.
Hier Brightness.
Ah doch, tatsächlich.
Ja, aber brighter so kannst du nicht machen.
Also was halt wirklich nicht gescheit geht, ist Gamma Settings.
Ich habe noch keine Möglichkeit gefunden, gescheit Gamma Settings und sowas unter KDE anzupassen.
Das einzige, was man machen kann, ist, man kann
Custom-Color-Profile laden.
Ja, man kann Custom-Color-Profile laden,
wo Gamma hochgestellt wird.
Gibt es denn, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
scheiß drauf, wir fangen mit Rust, wir fangen schon gleich an.
Gibt es da was?
Wayland, Control,
Control-Gamma.
Gnome-Gamma-Tool.
K-Gamma 2.
K-Gamma.
Ups.
Okay.
Adjust your monitor gamma settings.
K-Gamma.
K.
Äh.
Ich hab das jetzt installiert.
Und jetzt?
Äh.
Okay, und wie...
Wie öffne ich das jetzt?
Okay.
K-Gamma.
Keine Ahnung.
Wer ist der Nummer 1?
Das ist dem Zuschauer überlassen.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich es nicht bin.
Du brauchst K-Gamma 2.
Aha.
Ah.
Aber, aber, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ähm, Pac-Man lists files inside package.
Leute, 6-7 Zuschauer.
Ich weiß, es ist schon wieder komplett outdated.
Jetzt sind es 69, jetzt sind es 80.
ich so also ql ql ql k gamma was ist dabei user local ganz toll user lib plugins system settings
Okay, da ist gar kein Binary dabei
Man muss in die
Man muss in die Settings
Gamma, geht nicht
Okay
Also so macht man das schon mal, ne?
Wir können auch
Ich will jetzt echt wissen, wie man die Gamma-Settings anpasst
Also das K-Gamma funktioniert schon mal nett.
Aber das ist die richtige Version auch, ne?
K-Gamma-Valent.
Gnome-Gamma-Tool.
Okay.
Wir suchen einfach mal nach Gamma, was es da so alles gibt.
Gamma-Ray.
Gamma-Step.
xorg xgr wahrscheinlich wl sunset
gamma step
jetzt ist immer das ist wieder so ein punkt bei wayland was mich echt abfragt wo ich so denke
Ey, das ist doch ein super krasses Basic-Zeug, ja?
So quasi Color Temperature und Gamma und Gedöns anpassen zu können.
Gamma Wayland.
Kann ich WL Sunset und dann von Hand was installieren?
Von Hand das anpassen?
Was haben wir ansonsten noch zu bieten?
Gamma...
Gamma Control
für KDE Plasma Sessions.
Wir installieren...
Wir installieren erstmal...
Ups. Wir installieren erstmal das
und gucken, was man damit so machen kann.
WL Sunset.
Äh... Minus G.
Minus G.
Minus G1.
Oh, jetzt ist wieder Wayland-Geschiss, weil KDE das nicht implementiert.
Dieses komische Protokoll.
Oh, Wayland, MonkaS.
Fuck mich nicht ab, Wayland.
Wisst ihr, manchmal frage ich mich, wieso wirklich so komplett Basic-Shit nach 30 Jahren oder wie lange es Wayland schon gibt,
20 Jahren oder so Wayland.
Warum es immer noch
keine Settings gibt?
KDE Plasma.
How to adjust
Gamma. Da muss doch irgendwas geben.
X11 Wayland Session.
Man muss wirklich... Das kenne ich.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Man muss das über Color Profiles
machen. Das ist wirklich abartig.
K Gamma 2.
Okay, dann installieren wir das.
Wo ist das auf GitHub irgendwo?
Aua, K Gamma 2.
Wir gucken mal, wo das herkommt.
Wo kommt das her? Wo ist das?
Die Suchs.
Wo ist das Suchs? Hier.
Codeberg. Nee. KDE.
K Gamma 2 sollen wir...
Okay, machen wir. K Gamma 2.
Bam.
bämm bämm
remove make dependencies after install yes yes jetzt wird erstmal drei stunden
kompiliert weil c++
und dann machen wir rust aber erstmal ordentliche sachen wie gamma settings
Yes.
Da fehlt doch noch ein Tool.
Placingly fast written in Rust, oder?
GitHub Wayland Gamma.
WL Gamma.
Gnome Gamma Tool.
WL Gamma CTL.
Guck mal, da gibt es doch.
Da gibt es doch einige Sachen.
Okay.
K Gamma.
Wayland.
Aha.
Huge.
Äh.
Warum ist es jetzt dunkler geworden?
Jetzt ist es heller geworden?
Hä?
Wow.
Äh.
Moment.
Zwei?
Zwei ist default, oder was?
Hä?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Hat das sowas wie ein Reset drin?
Weil das ist zu dunkel.
Nee, hat natürlich kein Reset.
Guck mal, man kann wieder nicht richtig.
Ja, so ist okay.
Und volle Pulle?
Mehr geht auch nicht.
Hier, K-Gamma-Forced-ICC.
Ah, der macht das selbst.
Alter, das Ding erzeugt...
Das ist ja ein Low IQ...
Oh, was heißt Low IQ?
Ne, ne, ne Krücke dieses Tool.
Also ich dachte, das Tool ist gut, ja?
Aber die Möglichkeit ist ja ne Krücke.
Der generiert on the fly ECC-Profile.
Hier, der generiert ECC-Profile.
War das schon immer so dunkel, Leute, wie jetzt?
War das schon immer so dunkel?
Nee, oder?
Keine Ahnung.
Mir kommt es vor, als ist es jetzt dunkler.
Mir kommt vor, als ist es jetzt dunkler wie vorher.
Aber gut, wie dem auch sei.
Stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt.
Chat, wir machen das jetzt einfach hier auf
2,39. Perfekt.
Excellent.
2,39.
So lassen wir das.
K-Gamma. Es ist eine
pfeifertige Idee, das über
ECC-Profile zu machen, aber
trotzdem finde ich, dass es
überhaupt notwendig ist. Finde ich das echt dumm.
Tool
to adjust gamma colors
tint for Wayland Compositors.
Kein Release, okay.
Gnome Gamma Tool.
Kein Release.
Ähm.
Zwei Jahre alt.
WL Gamma CTL.
Ne, das unterstützt das Ding ja nicht.
Das haben wir ja ausprobiert.
Das kann der KDE nicht.
gamma ctl ja just display gamma und kde plasma 3 cc profile genau das gleiche okay jetzt ist
Gamma CTRL.
Naja.
Naja, Leute.
So geil ist das nicht.
Also das finde ich schon etwas schwach,
dass das nur über
Pap-Profile geht.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich HDR enable?
Oh
Äh
Es sieht extrem kacke aus
Ich rewarte das mal wieder
SRGB Color Intensity
Okay, erkennt man gar nichts
Okay, bevor ich da jetzt noch ewig drin rumklicke
draufgeschissen, zack, machen wir zu
Wir haben jetzt Gamma, es müsste jetzt
Chat, ich guck mir das mal kurz auf meinem Vorschau-Monitor an
Es müsste jetzt einen
Ticken heller sein als
vorher, oder?
Aber ich finde es ist angenehm zu gucken
Oder ist zu hell
Nö, ich finde das ist gut
Ich finde das ist gut
Erkennt man wenigstens ordentlich was
Gehst du weg?
Ist gut? Nice
Excellent
Wisst ihr, da sieht man mal wieder so
Dinger, wo ich mir denke, das kann doch nicht sein
Dass das unter Wayland
Nach 500 Jahren immer noch nicht funktioniert
Aber ist anscheinend so
Weil Wayland ist ja nicht Wayland
Wayland ist ja nur die Spezifikation
Und alle implementieren den Kram extra
Nicht so wie bei X
X war zwar vielleicht bei Design kaputt,
aber zumindest hatten sie
einen gemeinsamen Unterbau.
Aber X
ist auch abfuck. Es gibt nichts.
Das ist halt das Ding.
Das ist so ein typisches Linux-Ding, ja?
Da wurden
zig Projekte gestartet
und Jahrzehnte rumgefuddelt,
aber was richtig gescheit ist,
ist nicht rausgekommen.
Es gab ja mal eine Zeit, da hat jeder Anbieter versucht, was eigenes zu machen
Es gab
Also es gab X, es gab Wayland
Und es gab
Von Canonical gab es noch was
Ich glaube von Redhead gab es auch noch was
Ich glaube das war es
Es ist alles nicht weiter verfolgt worden
Jetzt haben wir Wayland
Und ich meine, Wayland ist wirklich alt
Wayland ist keine Ahnung, 20 Jahre alt oder so mittlerweile.
Und
Wayland ist
erst die letzten
2-3 Jahre wirklich
gut benutzbar geworden.
So mit immer mehr
Edge Cases, dass es halt funktioniert.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die sind immer noch ziemlich
Paints Champ. Ja, zum Beispiel
VNC und Remote Desktop.
Versucht mal
hier
auf Wayland
einen RDP-Server laufen zu lassen.
Oder hier auf KDE.
Es ist zwar was eingebaut,
aber das ist richtig...
Ich weiß gar nicht...
Bei KDE ist was eingebaut.
Das ist aber richtig mies.
Du musst dich vorher angemeldet haben,
Monitor dran haben,
dich eingeloggt haben in der Session,
dass das RDP geht.
Also Headless-RDP und so funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Bei Gnome funktioniert es,
aber Gnome ist halt per Design schon mal kacke.
Ist alles nicht so geil.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass X toll ist, ne?
Ganz im Gegenteil.
By the way, was macht eigentlich, wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Was macht eigentlich X Libre so?
Ich hab gehört, der Typ wurde letztens wieder in irgendeinem Forum gebannt.
Weiß nicht mehr, was war denn das?
Gentoo?
Nee.
irgendeine Distro, die
X-Libre wieder rausgeschmissen hat.
Also keine Ahnung, was mit dem los ist.
Oh.
Ich merke es noch ein bisschen, Leute.
Leute, ich muss mal
Ich muss mal ein bisschen entspannter reden.
Ich merke es noch voll im Hals von heute Morgen.
Keine Ahnung.
Das muss ja auch nicht sein.
So.
Machen wir mal unser
Rust-Repo auf.
Und connecten uns mit der IDE rein.
Warte mal, bis die IDE gestartet ist.
Hallo?
IDE Champ?
Starten, please.
Ah, jetzt.
Das ist beim First Boot
oder Starten nicht so flott.
Ne, ich trinke nichts und ich rauche nichts.
Ich lebe eigentlich
insgesamt ausgesprochen
gesund.
Das Einzige, was ich hab, ist, ich hab
jahrelang kaum Sport gemacht,
war zu fett. Das war nicht gesund,
aber das ist jetzt vorbei. Jetzt bin ich
nur noch fett, aber nicht mehr
unsportlich.
Wobei, so fett bin ich nicht mehr.
Ich mein, ich hab 25 Kilo oder so
abgenommen. Jetzt geht's.
Ich wiege jetzt 85 Kilo oder so.
Ich bin
1,74. Das ist immer noch zu schwer.
letztes jahr hatte ich mal 80 aber ich habe pippo fett gemacht pippo fett
gefressen
der romanschrei max ich habe mega angst vor meiner neuen stelle die ich am
ersten elften antrete aus der noch eineinhalb monate zeit und ich bin mega
aufregt. Vor elf Jahren im Ausbildungsbetrieb
hast du Tipps. Was ist es denn für eine
Stelle? Und also erst einmal andersrum
gefragt, warum? Warum hast du da
so Bedenken? Ich meine,
die werden dich ja nicht ohne Grund eingestellt haben.
Und wenn du denen nicht total was aufs Ohr erzählt
hast, so nach dem Motto, ich bin
VMW-Experte und das Einzige, was du
gemacht hast, ist einmal Ubuntu installieren,
dann sollte das ja kein Problem sein.
Ach, Quatsch.
Leute, Leute,
du musst dir keine Gedanken machen.
Es gibt da mehrere Typen von Leuten. Du hast einmal so diese, wie nennen wir sie mal, diese Berater-Style-Leute, die es perfektioniert haben, überhaupt keine Ahnung zu haben, aber kompetent rüber zu kommen.
Wo es immer so klingt, als hätten die den mega Durchblick, aber sobald du mal ein bisschen nachfragst, haben die keine Ahnung.
Dann gibt es umgedreht die Leute, die mega Durchblick haben und sich nicht trauen, was zu sagen und alles mögliche dazwischen.
aber ich würde mir wenig gedanken zu machen du hast du die du hast du das
vorstellungsgespräch und weiß ich was sie da alles gemacht haben überlebt die
haben sich nicht ohne grund eingestellt und dazu kommt nur weil du eine
technologie kennst muss hier keine gedanken machen dass du an dem ich muss
anders anfangen also nur weil du eine technologie kennst heißt ja noch lange
nicht dass du weißt wie der jeweilige betrieb oder wie die jeweilige firma
das einsetzt selbst wenn ich jetzt sagen würde ich habe keine ahnung 300 jahre kuba netz erfahrung
und ich komme in eine neue firma heißt es noch lange nicht dass ich weiß wie ich da alles machen
muss selbst wenn ich im cloud und kuba netz umfeld arbeiten würde weil jeder laden tickt anders jeder
laden hat andere workflows andere vorgaben andere tools drumherum benutzt die sachen anders und da
Da kommst du eh mit Ohrkenntnissen nicht weiter, weil man das nicht außerhalb der jeweiligen Firma erlangen kann.
Und denk auch dran, dass die dich ordentlich einarbeiten, liegt ja in ihrem ureigenen Interesse.
Die wollen ja, dass du was auf die Reihe kriegst.
Sonst geben sie ja umsonst Geld aus.
Also da würde ich mir keine Gedanken machen.
Du musst nicht von Anfang an irgendwie zeigen, du bist der Geilste oder so
Das ist je nachdem, was du für Leute im Team hast
Hast du da vielleicht eher Probleme
Ich denke, das Wichtigste ist
Dass du gerade am Anfang guckst, wie der Laden läuft
Das ist fast noch wichtiger
als irgendwelche
krassen
Hardware, Software, Proggers,
Cloud-Skills.
Man muss erstmal, die ersten paar Wochen
und Monate, muss man ein Gefühl
dafür bekommen, wie der jeweilige Laden läuft
und wie da Sachen
gemacht werden. Das macht jeder Laden anders.
Du solltest dir einen Laptop aussuchen.
Das heißt, die haben da verschiedene, oder was?
Kein Einheitslaptop.
Naja, dann würde ich sagen, nehmen wir es mit viel RAM, oder?
Da hast du große, wichtige Frage, Robin, die jetzt kommt.
Ganz wichtige Frage.
Freie Betriebssystemwahl, ja oder nein?
Das würde mich jetzt noch interessieren.
Weil wenn freie Betriebssystemwahl...
Ist schon mal nice.
Okay, das...
Warum ist das in C++ geproggert eigentlich?
Lass mal kurz gucken, ob das schön ist, C++ ist.
Es ist...
Naja.
C++ ist eigentlich nie schön.
Aber das ist zumindest C++, was man lesen kann.
Aber selbst lesbares C++ ist Paintschamp.
Guckt euch das an, Alter.
Das ist lesbares C++.
Kannst du auch verstehen.
Wobei, kommen wir mal zu Rust.
Heißt ja nicht, dass man das unbedingt versteht.
Oh Leute, wir haben schon eine Viertelstunde keine Updates gemacht.
Wie sieht's aus?
Package Updates?
Yes!
keine excellent bleeding edge time du darfst frei das betriebssystem wählen sehr schön geliehen
wie früher auch 16 g gramm ja aber da kommt so ein linox laptop kommst du da hin ja cool dass
das spricht schon mal für die firma das ist frei betriebssystem wahl gibt wobei das auch dafür
spricht dass es nicht die allergrößte das ist nicht so ein riesenkonzern ist weil da gibt so
was meist nicht so gehen wir mal hier unser rost projekt also leute ich
versuche die streams ja immer so also habe ich mir vorgenommen
ich versuche die ja immer so aufzuteilen dass man gucken kann ohne dass man den
letzten stream geschaut hat deswegen benutzen wir halt nichts wirklich von
dem was wir heute was das letzte mal gemacht haben waren gleiche neue datei
und
Es geht also mein versuch ist folgendes
Ich habe usb gerät ja ich stöpsel ich stöpsel mal kurz das usb gerät ein ok
auf ihrem blumen
macht es gleich usb gerät
Ja usb device detected ihr werdet sehen wir haben jetzt hier usb jaja wir haben jetzt hier usb gerät
Achso ich bin im container da habe ich das natürlich nicht
usb gerät
Seriennummer 123, beste Seriennummer.
Sehr vertrauenswürdig, auf jeden Fall.
Also das ist ein Gerät, damit kann man wireless verschiedene Sensoren abfragen.
Und ich will das Gerät wirklich RAW auslesen.
Also ich will keinen fertigen Treiber benutzen, um das auszulesen, sondern ich will das RAW über USB machen.
Wir haben uns das letzte Mal schon ein bisschen angeguckt, so ganz grob, wie das geht.
Also wir öffnen hier das USB-Gerät und dann lesen wir was.
Ich kann mal kurz die Anwendung starten, wie gesagt, wir machen das gleich weg.
Aber da sind wir das letzte Mal stehen geblieben.
Musst du mal gerade suchen, wie wir das gemacht haben, so glaube ich.
App.
so also hier seht ihr usb geduld ist gestartet die weiß wird gefunden und wir können auch was
an das usb also wir können auch was schreiben auf das usb gerät hier guck das sind beides
das sind beides die wir aufs usb gerät geschrieben haben das ist das ist ein hardware reset command
Das hilft voll.
Exzellent.
Was?
Wir könnten lediglich auf einen Mac wechseln?
Müssten dafür aber etwas von unserem Gehalt abgeben?
Was?
Sind die noch ganz bei Trost?
Wenn du einen Mac hast, bist du schneller, effektiver, besser dran als unter Windows?
Du arbeitest mehr und du sollst dafür weniger Gehalt kriegen?
The fuck?
Wer hat sich den Scheiß ausgedacht bei euch?
Das ist ja richtig dumm.
Das ist ja richtig, das ist ja mega dumm hängen geblieben.
Richtig scam.
Ja.
Diesen Kram hier, das können wir gleich alles weg machen.
Aber das ist das Ziel.
Wie gesagt, ich will vom USB-Gerät, will ich Bytes schreiben und Bytes auslesen.
Das hier schieben wir jetzt einfach in eine eigene Datei, weil das brauchen wir gleich noch.
USB-Gerät, Open.
Aber diesen anderen Krempel hier, Data, Send Data und so, das brauchen wir eigentlich nicht mehr.
Das machen wir alles weg.
Zack.
Und das schieben wir jetzt mal in eine eigene Datei.
Wie macht man das hier mit der IDE gescheit?
So, rechtsklick.
Hallo, rechtsklick.
Äh, refactor.
Move.
Kein Framework.
Was meinst du? Für USB?
Hey, wir lesen RAW Bytes aus.
Also wir wollen
das da verschieben in eine Datei.
Keine Ahnung.
USB.
Device.
RS.
Achso, Notebook Frame.
Refactor Anyway.
Okay.
Achja.
Das müssen wir jetzt noch Papp machen.
Jetzt wird das nix.
Und schon funktioniert es.
Ist wieder übersichtlich. Wir können loslegen.
Excellent.
So, also.
Ich wollte mir heute mal zwei verschiedene Sachen angucken.
Und zwar, wie man ordentliches Error-Handling in Rust macht.
Dazu gibt es zwei...
Ich habe mir dazu schon ein Tutorial angeguckt.
Libraries in Rust.
Die wohl recht beliebt sind.
Die Rust-Checker unter euch, die können mir ja gleich mal sagen, ob ich das richtig...
Haben wir überhaupt Rust-Checker da?
Ist da Tommy am Start? Der hat sich doch das letzte Mal... Der kennt sich doch gut aus.
Zumindest...
Ihr könnt ja mal sagen, ob das Mist ist, was ich erzähle.
Und zwar, ich habe mir ein Video angeguckt zum Thema Rust-Error-Handling im Vorfeld.
Und es gibt zwei Libraries, die da saumäßig verbreitet sind.
Das ist einmal ThisError und das ist einmal Anyhow.
So, der Unterschied ist folgendes.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, man benutzt, fangen wir mal anders an,
man benutzt ThisError für eigene Error-Typen.
Ja, also wenn man jetzt Funktionen hat, die einen Error returnen, so wie das hier zum Beispiel,
dann returnt man nicht hier diesen Default-Error, wo eigentlich nichts drin ist,
sondern kann damit, kann mit thisError, kann man eigene Error-Typen anlegen,
wo dann auch Felder drin sind, wo man dann auch sagen kann,
hier Reason, TimeoutSeconds und Message und alles mögliche.
Also ein bisschen sowas, ein bisschen sowas wie in C-Sharp.
Wie hieß der Kram in C-Sharp?
Exception, Custom, CustomException.
Also ein bisschen sowas wie Custom Exceptions in C Sharp. Nur dass es halt keine Exceptions sind. Also man kann quasi so einen eigenen Error-Typ anlegen. In C Sharp sind es Exceptions, dementsprechend auch mit eigener Syntax. Rust hat keine Exceptions. Rust hat so ein bisschen wie Go, nur verschiedene Return-Types.
Also, es ist ein Rust. Ich versuche das mal zu erklären.
Wie gesagt, ich bin selbst nicht der langjährige Rust-Kenner.
Ich lerne das selbst noch.
Also, es gibt in Rust zwei verschiedene Varianten.
Machen wir mal eine Function, okay?
Hier, get Chatter.
Okay, das ist unsere Function.
Und hier machen wir jetzt irgendwas.
Bla, bla, get Chatter.
Und hier unten...
Es gibt jetzt zwei Sachen hier.
Let.
Der Chatter wurde gefunden.
Dann...
Wir machen das jetzt mal ganz.
Wenn der Chatter gefunden wurde...
Dann...
Returnen wir den Chatter.
In dem Fall...
Wen haben wir hier?
Der Robin.
95.
Pomm.
und wenn wir den, ich mach das gleich richtig,
also hier oben, hier, super krasse Function,
hier passiert normalerweise ein bisschen was,
und wir können es ja mal anders machen.
Ich erkläre es jetzt aber erstmal.
Wenn das gefunden wird, dann return ich den User.
Wenn das nicht gefunden wird, was mache ich denn dann?
Was mache ich dann?
In C Sharp würde ich jetzt sagen
Throw new exception
So nach dem Motto hier
Chatter not found oder irgendwie so etwas
Das würde ich in C Sharp machen
Und wenn ich das dann aufrufe
Ja, dann müsste ich in C Sharp
So was hier machen, try
Bla bla bla
Accepts bla irgendetwas
Das gibt es in Rust nicht, okay
Das gibt es in Rust nicht
In Rust gibt es
Zwei
Grundsätzlich
also erstmal grundsätzlich zwei
Return-Typen, die man dafür verwenden kann.
Es gibt einmal Option,
in dem Fall Option of String.
Option sagt
einfach nur aus,
ob es ein Ergebnis gibt,
oder ob es kein Ergebnis gibt. Und wenn es ein Ergebnis
gibt, was das Ergebnis für ein Typ hat.
Und das funktioniert folgendermaßen,
hier returne ich den Robin, und hier
returne ich dann, ja was?
None.
gibt nichts. Und das muss ich hier noch
rappen, dass das funktioniert.
Das heißt,
I went to
string.
Wer sich jetzt fragt, ist das hier nicht ein String?
Warum muss ich ein String to String machen?
Rust-Logik.
Ich erzähle euch jetzt einfach ein bisschen was, was
ich über Rust gelernt habe, weil
erstens bin ich Deutschlands zweitbester Rust-Streamer
und zweitens kann ich mir dann
besser merken.
Also in Rust ist es so,
kleine Side-Tour jetzt.
Das hier ist in Rust
kein String.
Das hier ist ein String Slice.
Das ist ein Pointer.
Das ist quasi
ein Zeiger dahin,
wo der String steht.
Ein String Pointer in Rust
ist im Endeffekt halt
eine Speicheradresse mit einer Länge.
Das ist ein String-Pointer.
Wenn man jetzt allerdings keinen Pointer haben will,
sondern einen, wie das in Rust so schön heißt,
Owned String,
also keine Referenz auf den String,
sondern wirklich die Daten direkt,
dann
muss man
dieses String Slice
to String machen.
Ja, weil Rust
hat ja, da muss ich jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter ausholen,
das müsst ihr entscheiden, wer Deutschlands bester Rust Streamer ist.
Weil Rust hat ja
das Konzept
zwischen,
wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Ausleihen und Besitzen.
glaube ich, heißt das auf Deutsch, also
Borrowing
und Borrow und
Ownership.
Und anhand dessen
kann Rust erkennen, ob
Ressourcen genutzt sind oder nicht.
Also wenn ich jetzt sowas hier mache,
dann machen wir jetzt irgendwie sowas hier
und
irgendwie keine Ahnung, blubb.
So, und wenn ich hier den String Slice übergebe,
an meine Funktion,
Und ich mache jetzt hier so.
Dann klappt das.
Was jetzt allerdings nicht klappt, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
Wir machen jetzt mal hier, blub, gleich.
Jetzt übergebe ich das an die Funktion hier.
Kunst, alles, noch kein Problem.
Kunst, auch alles, mehrfach aufrufen, kein Problem.
Okay.
Jetzt sage ich aber, es ist ein OwnString.
Achso, und hier sage ich
toString.
Und jetzt werdet ihr sehen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe,
das funktioniert nicht mehr.
Guck mal, das funktioniert nur
einmal. Danach funktioniert es
nicht mehr. Warum?
Weil das jetzt keine Referenz mehr ist,
sondern der Value
wird jetzt gemovt. Also quasi
diese Funktion
kriegt jetzt den String.
Den kommt...
den übergeben.
Also in Rust sagt man dann,
diese Funktion
ownt jetzt den String.
Du übergibst dem den String, was sie damit macht, ist egal.
Du kannst
bloß am Ende, weil der String
jetzt ja diesem Funktionsaufruf hier gehört,
ist die Variable danach
nicht mehr gültig. Ihr erkennt schon
sofort, wenn ihr mal C++ verwendet habt,
das behebt
eines der größten
Schwachstellen und Probleme,
die es in C++ gab.
Nämlich, dass du Sachen benutzt,
nachdem sie nicht mehr gültig sind.
Das geht in Rust nicht.
Rust trackt,
wer
wem was gehört.
Und dementsprechend, ich kann einen
ownString an diese Funktion
geben,
aber danach kann ich
die Variable nicht mehr verwenden.
Was ich jetzt machen kann, ist,
ich kann sagen,
Ich will einen String Slice, also einen Pointer haben.
Das ist wiederum okay.
Ups.
Allerdings.
Haha.
Sollte das hier out of scope gehen.
Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz husten.
Sollte das hier in irgendeiner Art und Weise out of scope gehen.
Dann funktioniert das auch nicht.
Und...
Rust trackt das auch.
Ja, also wenn wir jetzt hier mal...
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Irgendwie sowas, ja?
Keine Ahnung.
Na gut, nee, das funzt nicht.
Wie simuliere ich denn das Out of Scope-Gen jetzt am besten?
Keine Ahnung.
Fällt mir jetzt gerade nichts Gescheines ein.
Ah, ich hab was, genau.
Ich kann es von Hand droppen, du hast recht.
Ich kann es von Hand droppen.
Ich kann sagen, das ist jetzt nicht mehr gültig.
Äh.
Was, was, was hab ich jetzt verkehrt gemacht?
was ist dann was du zeigen willst
das funktioniert jetzt ja weil das hier das gefällt jetzt haben wir fällen
jetzt nichts gescheites ein ich wollte jetzt zeigen was ist wenn das auto auf
scope geht
Ähm.
Weiß nicht, jetzt fällt mir jetzt gar nichts Gescheites ein.
Aber zumindest Rust
trackt das.
Und sollte diese Variable
nicht mehr hier im Scope sein, gehen die Aufrufe nicht.
Also das ist so eines der Dinge, was
Rust sehr viel
sicherer macht, ohne
Runtime Overhead
zu haben.
Ich glaube, das Einzige, was Rust noch ein bisschen
Runtime Overhead hat, sind teilweise
Dynamic Dispatch und
Array Bound
Checks. Das gibt es
in Rust noch. Also dementsprechend, da
verschenkst du ein bisschen Performance.
Wirklich, ein bisschen.
Aber Rust trackt halt
sehr genau, wie die Lifetime
von Variablen sind.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht,
wie ich das am besten checken soll.
Hier ist ein Scope.
Wenn ich das hier reinmache, kann ich ja da unten nicht mehr aufrufen.
Also wie gesagt, wenn das
out of scope geht, dann...
Ich kann euch... Doch, ich kann euch was zeigen.
Ja, ja. Ich sag nicht,
dass Rust...
Dass das was ist, was besser ist.
Als in C++.
Aber ich weiß, was wir machen können. Wir können
sagen, Tokio, spawn.
Wir spawnen jetzt einen Task.
Also Background Thread.
Da weiß ich aber die...
Nicht, wie man es...
die Syntax genau macht, ehrlich gesagt.
Async, move.
So. Okay, so macht man das.
Äh...
Nein.
Äh, ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Tokio Spawn.
Example please.
Example.
Tokio Spawn.
Hab ich doch gemacht.
Ah man darf da keine.
Ah ja.
Okay.
Chat kann mir einer erklären.
Warum das jetzt funktioniert.
Achso, weil ich es gemovt habe.
Ich will es nicht moven.
Chat, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das funktioniert.
Weil theoretisch könnte das hier doch droppen, während der Task noch läuft.
Ich warte ja nicht auf den.
Warum geht das?
Warum funktioniert das?
Das verstehe ich jetzt Rust-technisch nicht.
Da ist Rust 5
halt egal. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, das geht nicht.
Weil, guck mal,
diese Referenz hier, oder diese Variable,
die wird aufgeräumt, sobald die Funktion zu Ende ist.
Aber dieser Task hier, der kann
länger laufen. Wird das vielleicht
kopiert? Oder ist das ein
Sonderfall von String?
Können wir mal ausprobieren.
Wir machen jetzt hier einfach mal eine Zahl.
Okay?
nehmen davon jetzt mal
eine Referenz.
Sagen wir, wir wollen eine Referenz auf
Usize oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Das geht auch.
Okay, whatever. Vergesst, was ich euch erzählen
wollte. Ich bin zu doof für Rust-Features zu
demonstrieren. Aber
ich kann euch sagen, Rust
trackt das eigentlich.
Das ist eine statische Referenz,
die gibt es so lange, wie das Programm gibt.
Warum ist das hier eine statische Referenz?
Warum ist das statisch? Das ist eine ganz normale Variable hier in meiner Funktion.
Warum ist das statisch?
Okay, dann nehme ich mal irgendwas anderes. Was ist denn nicht statisch?
Hier, mein USB-Interface ist nicht statisch, okay?
USB-Interface.
Nehmen wir mal einen Pointer von meinem USB-Interface.
Ach, also alles, was du quasi als Kunst im Source-Code stecken hast, ist für die gesamte Programmlaufzeit gültig.
Ah, verstehe.
Okay, aber mein USB-Device.
Mein USB-Device sollte jetzt eigentlich expiren.
Und USB-Device.
Gucken wir mal.
Äh, funktioniert nicht.
Chat, ich... Ah, jetzt geht's nicht, okay.
Ja.
Genau. Jetzt funktioniert's nicht.
Das ist eigentlich das, was ich zeigen wollte.
Guck mal. Weil Rust ist so schlau.
Rust erkennt jetzt
diese Variable hier.
Die wird automatisch aufgeräumt, hier, wenn der Block vorbei ist.
Und hier spawne ich ein Background-Task.
Der läuft im Hintergrund weiter, auch wenn die Funktion zu Ende ist.
Und Rust erkennt jetzt, ich greife hier auf eine Variable zu, die vielleicht nicht mehr da ist, wenn ich sie benutzen will.
Dementsprechend sagt Rust hier, Async-Block may outlive the current function.
Also das ist diese Geschichte, die Rust im Endeffekt im Hintergrund beim Kompilieren trackt.
Und deswegen ist Rust eines der Gründe in einigen Punkten sicherer als C++.
Aber eigentlich wollte ich das an der Stelle gar nicht zeigen.
Ich wollte eigentlich was zum Thema Return-Werte erzählen.
Und zwar, es gibt grundsätzlich zwei verschiedene Return-Werte.
Oder muss ich das anders sagen?
Ja.
Es gibt zwei verschiedene Typen, die man von der Funktion zurückgeben kann, um anzuzeigen, es gibt einen Wert oder es gibt keinen Wert.
So, weil hier könnte es jetzt ja sein, in dieser Funktion getChatter, die übrigens gar kein USB-Device eigentlich braucht,
entweder wird der Chatter gefunden
dann gibt er den zurück
oder aber
der Chatter wird nicht gefunden, da gibt er None zurück
also wie gesagt
in C Sharp würde man jetzt hier vielleicht eine Exception werfen
oder was auch immer
in Go würde man das übrigens ähnlich machen
in Go würde ich beispielsweise sagen
String oder Error
letztendlich ist das hier in Rust
die gleiche Variante
Wobei, Error ist noch ein bisschen was anderes.
Da kommen wir gleich zu.
Also sprich, so kannst du in Rust sagen, ey, guck mal, gibt's das oder gibt's das nicht?
Wir können mal kurz gucken, wir können das sogar mal hier nachbauen.
Wir sagen jetzt hier einfach found random.
Rant.
Random.
Wie macht man das?
Einfach so?
Ne.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wie macht man
eine Random?
Standard Random?
Okay, whatever.
Rand.
Rust.
Bool.
Random Bool.
Ah.
Random.
Random Bool.
Und jetzt einfach so?
Was will der von mir?
One Argument.
Was will das für ein Argument bei Random Bull?
Äh.
Ein Float?
Ist das der Seed oder was?
Nee, hä?
Warum muss ich da was angeben für
einen Random?
Okay, das ist
richtig Massive High IQ, keine Ahnung.
Aber was ist P?
Ah
Achso
Das ist
Okay, das ist sogar ganz clever
Das ist mit welcher Wahrscheinlichkeit
Ey, das ist eigentlich eine richtig gute Funktion
Sehen wir uns dann gleich für den Sub
Das ist eigentlich eine richtig schlaue Funktion
Mit welcher Wahrscheinlichkeit der True zurückgeben soll
Also könnte ich jetzt
Könnte ich jetzt hier sagen 50
Oder
Oder könnte ich
Ich muss wahrscheinlich sagen 0,5 oder
ist 0,5, 50%?
Wahrscheinlich.
Okay, das ist eigentlich ziemlich schlau von den Rust-Leuten.
So.
Und ihr seht,
jetzt kann es random passieren,
dass der Chatter gefunden wird
oder nicht. Machen wir das jetzt mal.
Geben wir das Ganze hier mal aus.
Machen wir hier.
Tracing.
wir das mal als warning ok warning und jetzt get cheddar
oder wir machen es anders die back die back erkennt man es besser die back get cheddar
Zack, jetzt starten wir das mal
Man sieht hier, ich mach mal dieses USB-Gedöns hier unten weg
Das brauchen wir gar nicht
Man sieht jetzt
Hier ist der Return-Wert
Von der Function Sum
Und da ist der Name vom Chatter drin
Und wenn wir das jetzt noch ein paar mal starten
Dann
Haben wir aber echt Glück gehabt
Bei einer Chance von 50%
Das ist so oft in der Landshut
da sieht man manchmal ist der Chatter auch NUM.
Also es gibt keine Exceptions in Rust.
Du machst das alles über Return-Werte.
So, und dann gibt es noch einen zweiten Fall
und der ist jetzt ein bisschen wie Error-Handling in Rust.
Die Option, die zeigt ja nur an,
gibt es einen Return-Wert oder gibt es keinen Return-Wert.
Manchmal will man ja einen Return-Wert zurückgeben
oder aber eine Fehlermeldung,
was passiert ist so und dafür gibt es den wert result da kann man so was sagen wie hier result
und jetzt muss ich hier messe fragt mich bitte nicht was es genau ist angeben das ist das was
wir heute mit custom error typen fixen können und jetzt sagt man nicht sammeln sondern jetzt sagt
man ist okay oder ist ein fehler und wenn es ein fehler ist kann ich hier kann ich ja auch eine
Fehlermeldung angeben. So, keine Ahnung.
Äh, ganz
schlimmer Fehler.
So.
Auch zu einem String gescheit konvertieren und gut ist.
So, und jetzt seht ihr, ist der Return
wert.
Manchmal Error, ganz
schlimmer Fehler.
Und manchmal auch okay. So, und
jetzt ist die Frage, was mache ich jetzt
damit, wenn ich das Ganze bekomme?
Dafür gibt es in Rushed,
in Rushed,
ähm, dafür gibt es in Rushed
Match Expressions.
Also ich kann jetzt hier quasi sagen,
Chatter.
By the way, ich könnte an der Stelle jetzt auch Fragezeichen
machen, aber wir wollen es mal nicht so kompliziert
machen. Fragezeichen bricht an der Stelle
ab, wenn das Result nicht okay ist.
Chatter.
Ihr seht jetzt, ich bekomme
hier als Return Wert
kein String, sondern ein Result,
das entweder ein String sein kann
oder halt ein Error-Typ.
Und jetzt kann man sagen,
Match Chatter
Äh, nee. Chatter Match.
Nee, ich hatte es doch richtig.
Match Chatter, kann man sagen.
Und jetzt kann ich entscheiden, was mache ich denn in welchem Fall?
Was mache ich im Fall, dass das okay ist?
Was mache ich im Fall, dass es ein Error ist?
Da kann ich das ändern.
Das Ganze geht übrigens mit Option genauso.
Nur, dass ich dann sagen würde, ist Sum or None.
So, und jetzt ist es so.
Das ist das, was ich mir heute mal angucken wollte.
Jetzt ist es ja so,
es gibt ja durchaus
Fälle,
da will man eine Fehlermeldung
zurückgeben,
aber neben der Fehlermeldung
auch noch ein paar Infos.
Ja. Also,
stellt euch mal vor, ihr versucht
eine Datei zu öffnen.
Da kann es alle möglichen Fehler geben.
Permissions, äh,
keine permissions datei gibt es nicht
und zeug datei ist leer oder so oder kann es jede menge da kannst du jede menge
fehler geben und du willst vielleicht nicht nur wissen du willst vielleicht
nicht nur eine fehlermeldung nicht ausgeben kann sondern willst es
vielleicht auch im programm unterschiedlich handhaben also willst
zum Beispiel vielleicht sagen, ey, guck mal,
ich will in dem Fall,
dass Permission denied ist,
beziehungsweise, dass die Permissions nicht stimmen,
will ich was anderes machen,
wie wenn die Datei gar nicht da ist.
Vielleicht will ich den Fall,
dass die Datei gar nicht da ist, handeln,
indem ich dann die Datei anlege.
Ne, hab ich mir nicht,
hab ich mir nicht angeschaut.
Also, ich hab das auf GitHub mal gesehen.
Also, vielleicht will ich das ja anders handeln.
Und das geht ja mit diesem
Standard-Error-Typ nicht, weil dieser
Standard-Error-Typ,
der hat im Endeffekt nur eine Fehlermeldung, sonst nix.
Die Fehlermeldung kann ich
printen und das war's.
Was machen wir denn jetzt aber, wenn es hier
verschiedene Fehlermeldungen geben könnte, ja?
Es könnte zum Beispiel hier, es könnte die
Fehlermeldung geben. Timeout.
Es könnte die Fehler geben.
User not found.
Könnte es geben.
Ja.
User banned.
Zum Beispiel.
So, also das hier sind, sagen wir mal, mögliche Fehlermeldungen, die als Error in Betracht kommen, als Return-Wert von dieser Funktion.
Und wie mache ich das jetzt? Tja, das weiß ich selber nicht. Das wollte ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Ich habe nur gelesen, es gibt zwei verschiedene Crates, die da sehr beliebt sind.
Einmal this Error für Custom Error Types.
Und Anyhow als Wrapper für solche Dinger, wenn es einfach nur eine Message braucht.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, wir fangen mal mit Anyhow einfach an.
Und gucken uns das an, was man damit so machen kann.
Rust Anyhow.
Gucken wir uns mal ein Beispiel an.
Example.
Anyhow. GitHub. Haben die Example Repos?
Kannst doch Result dein Error-Enum.
Ja, kannst du machen.
Wobei ich mir da nicht sicher bin,
wie das funktioniert mit
Error-Händling. Keine Ahnung.
Das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Wir können auch
erst mal von Hand einen Error-Type
erstellen und gucken, was Sache ist.
Das können wir auch machen, ja.
Wir machen es mal von Hand.
Weil da habe ich auch keine Ahnung von.
Okay, also. Wir wollen jetzt, sagen wir mal,
wir wollen jetzt einen Custom-Error zurückgeben.
mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, wir machen sowas hier.
Wir machen einen Inam
mit verschiedenen Typen. Also hier
zum Beispiel
nehmen wir mal hier
Chatter Error, nennen wir das Ding mal.
Also das ist jetzt, ich habe jetzt auch keine Ahnung
davon, ja. So, Chatter Error
und
der hat verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Der hat einmal
Timeout,
User Not Found
und User Banned
oder sowas. Ja, whatever.
Keine Ahnung.
So, und da kann ich
jetzt sagen,
einfach so.
Okay, das schmeißt schon mal
keine Fehler.
Das hier funktioniert natürlich nicht.
So.
Und in dem Fall will ich jetzt
Error.
Kann ich jetzt hier sagen Chatter?
Ja, sagen wir keine Ahnung.
Hier unten ist User not found, okay?
Okay, das funktioniert schon mal. Das ist schon mal ganz praktisch.
Also jetzt kriegen wir hier im Endeffekt
manchmal...
Mal gucken.
Äh.
Was?
Ah!
Jetzt kann man das nicht ausgeben.
Kann man nicht sagen.
Hier Format.
So.
Das Non-Implement-Debug.
Okay.
Das heißt, Chatter, also das Ding hat keine Ahnung, wie man den Typ darstellen soll.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt Debug implementieren
Oder Derive
Ja, ja, mein Debug muss
Printbar gemacht werden
Bin ich eigentlich
Komisch, ne
Aber man kann jetzt
Sowas hier machen, das ist auch Rust Magic
Derive
Ne, wie ging das? So, gell
Da, da, und jetzt Derive
Debug
Ne, äh
Sekunde
Alter, wie ist die Sonntags dafür?
Derive Rust.
So, okay.
Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Ah, ohne Ausrufe.
Moment, warum gibt es das mit Ausrufezeichen hinten dran?
Was ist denn das?
Was ist denn das mit Ausrufezeichen hinten dran?
Kann man das auch so da oben dran schreiben oder was?
Okay, ich habe legit keine Ahnung, für was das Makro gut sein soll.
Aber so kann man drüber schreiben.
Jetzt ist der printbar.
Oh, guck.
Und ihr seht, jetzt ist der Chatter...
Hier, UserNotFoundError haben wir jetzt.
UserNotFoundError oder manchmal halt auch
okay.
Also so macht man anscheinend CustomErrorTypes.
Aber was ist denn jetzt? Jetzt muss ich mal überlegen.
Was ist denn jetzt, wenn
ich will,
dass mein Error
CustomProperties hat?
Kann ich dann irgendwie sowas hier machen?
Timeout.
Äh, Seconds?
Ne, das wär jetzt zu einfach, wenn ich sowas machen könnte.
Oder so?
Irgendwie geht das bestimmt.
Rust Enums with Properties.
Die runden Klammern müssen weg?
Okay.
Also sage ich dann sowas hier.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Duration.
Ah.
Okay.
Das ist ja sehr nice.
So, das heißt,
wenn wir jetzt, sagen wir jetzt mal, dass es hier unten
gibt, ist ein Timeout.
Chatter Error Timeout.
Timeout.
und jetzt sage ich was
Duration
ah
ok das finde ich cool
das finde ich cool
so und jetzt
und jetzt muss ich ja gucken
was ist es für ein Error der zurückkommt
also sagen wir hier Match
ok wenn es ok ist
dann
ja, gehen wir das zurück.
Wenn es ein Error ist,
dann matchen wir
nochmal auf den Error.
Vielleicht kann man das auch schöner machen, keine Ahnung.
Und jetzt muss ich auswählen, was mache ich denn?
In welchem
Errorfall?
Wie kann ich denn jetzt hier auf die
Timeout-Werte zugreifen?
Ne.
Was macht denn Punkt, Punkt, Punkt?
Okay, da bin ich zu blöd für.
Wie greife ich hier...
Okay, macht man hier vielleicht so?
Oh.
Jetzt eh.
Ne.
Wie greift man jetzt hier auf die Werte zu?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab kein Schimmer
Macht man da irgendwie ein X oder so?
Doch, E war richtig
Ne
Das ist nicht richtig
Ah, doch
Oder doch?
Ne
Der checkt es nicht
Wolltest du nicht mal wieder ein Video mit YouTube
Wieder machen? Doch, doch, doch, wollte ich
Add the names
To match a struct variance
fields. Also
quasi
quasi sowas hier.
Duration.
Ah, so macht man das.
Okay, boah, da muss der erstmal drauf kommen.
Geile Sonntags.
Und jetzt kann man
hier auf die Timeout Duration zugreifen.
Okay, nice, nice.
Alles klar, verstehe, verstehe.
Aber wenn man so einfach Custom Errors machen kann, Leute, wozu brauche ich denn dann zum Beispiel das Create This Error?
Was ist der Sinn da?
Ich dachte, das ist super kompliziert, Custom Errors zu machen. Das ist doch eigentlich ganz einfach.
Okay, was kann This Error so schön ist, was Custom Error Types nicht können?
Zeig mal her.
Ah, der kann schon direkt Fehlermeldungen da dran etachen.
Das heißt, wenn es disconnected ist und ich den Error printe, dann steht da Datastore
disconnected da und nicht einfach nur disconnected.
Man kann es aus anderen Errors
Konvertieren
Okay, das ist auch nicht verkehrt
Aber da verstehe ich jetzt
Nicht so genau, warum ich das verwenden sollte
Ehrlich gesagt
Also wenn man so einfach
wenn man so einfach
Custom-Typen machen kann.
Passt doch eigentlich.
So, aber Anyhow habe ich gesehen,
das muss wohl ganz gut sein
zum Tracen und
wo es Fehler gegeben hat.
Muss man das mal durchlesen.
Na, was?
Error Handling Series for Women.
Chat, das dürfen wir nicht lesen.
Ja, so schlau bin ich auch.
Und jetzt?
Aber wo ist das Problem?
Das kann ich doch auch mit allem anderen machen.
Also das verstehe ich jetzt nicht so wirklich.
Also ich meine, ob ich da jetzt den String schreibe hier mit einem Format in den Error oder Anyhow.
Ah, das bringt einen Custom Result Type mit.
Jetzt verstehe ich, das bringt einen Custom Result Type mit, dass ich nicht immer diesen Mist hier schreiben muss.
Okay, das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gecheckt.
Das Error ist für sowas hier.
Und Anyhow ist nur, wenn ich nur eine Textnachricht haben will.
Ich probiere es trotzdem mal aus.
Cargo at Anyhow.
Ja, ich könnte hier auch einfach
einen Type-Alias machen, ne?
Die coolen Kids nehmen Irie
Okay, Irie GitHub
Irie anstatt Anyhow
Okay
Why?
Hallo, Browser
Seite
Please öffnen.
Oh.
Memory shortage evaded.
Nein.
Der hat meine IDE gekillt.
Warum habe ich überhaupt eine Memory shortage?
Ich habe 8 Kicks.
Oh.
Warum habe ich Memory shortage?
Was ist da los?
F.
Warum ist mein Memory short, Leute?
Firefox zu fett, hä?
Firefox.
Eindeutig Firefox zu fett.
Firefox war 10 Gig groß.
Nee, es war Firefox.
Leute, ich muss da unbedingt mehr RAM einbauen.
Das Ding hat nur 8 Gig.
Und es muss noch 1024 MB an die Grafikkarte abgeben.
Okay, was ist jetzt an...
Was ist daran jetzt noch cooler?
Warum ist das besser als Anyhow?
Das ist ein Fork von Anyhow.
Hattest du nicht noch Ram rumfliegen, doch?
Ach, ist bei Irie die Fehlermeldung schöner?
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ich muss leider hier, nachdem das jetzt abgekackt ist,
mich nochmal in meinen Container connecten
und hoffen, dass ich jetzt nicht out of memory gehe wieder.
Ich hab noch 8 Gig hier im Nass.
Das muss ich einfach nur noch einbauen.
Aber ich war zu faul bisher.
Weil ich mir gedacht hab, ey, wir können auch einfach
8 Gig Swap dabei machen.
Aber es hat nicht gereicht.
Zu wenig Memory.
Leider.
ähm, hab ich,
brauchen wir da
SS0 oder SO-DIMM?
Sonst könnte ich einfach von meinem alten Rechner was nehmen.
Cargo at Anyhow.
Bam.
Da haben wir's. So, und, äh,
was bringt mir das jetzt genau? Wir probieren
das jetzt mal aus. Also, ich returne
jetzt hier,
ich returne jetzt hier,
nicht das da,
sondern,
Und das auch nicht.
Ich returne jetzt hier
Result.
Result
von Anyhow.
Anyhow
Result.
So, kann ich das nicht...
Kann ich das nicht importieren?
Dass ich das nicht zurückgeben muss?
Also kann ich so sagen?
Hier, sag.
Ich habe Standard Result drin,
wahrscheinlich deswegen hier schon oder so.
Wo habe ich das her?
Ist hier was drauf geschissen?
Wir machen das jetzt mal alles weg hier.
Bam.
Okay, man hat anscheinend
Result immer drin, oder?
Result ist, glaube ich,
so ein Standardtyp, den man nicht
drin haben kann.
Aber ich kann bestimmt sagen,
man kann bestimmt sagen,
Use Anyhow
Result.
Jetzt
funzt das hier.
So, jetzt find's das hier.
Kann man das jetzt hier vielleicht auch ganz weglassen?
Das wäre natürlich schlau.
Nee, geht nicht.
Das muss immer noch.
So, jetzt kann man hier...
So, wir returnen jetzt hier mal einen Error.
Einfach nur, um zu gucken, was passiert.
Ja.
Also, return.
Error.
Nee, wie mach ich das jetzt?
Anyhow.
Wie war das jetzt mit Errors returnen?
anyhow geht haben da kommt man mal ins example verzeichnis bale das gucken wir
uns jetzt mal ich hoffe meine rahme ist nicht wieder leer gleich monka es
sonst
wirklich schöne beispiele gibt es ja hier nicht oder er auch any bale a ok
import
Omega-Lul.
So, also das heißt, das kackt jetzt immer ab,
wenn ich das starte.
Error, Error, Missing Attribute.
Omega-Lul.
Und warum ist es jetzt wirklich so viel besser
als als der standard error typ ich glaube ich weiß warum ich glaube ich glaube ich habe eine idee
kann man hier kommt immer kann doch irgendwie kontext erden oder irgendwie sowas
ja gut das brauchen wir jetzt nicht
also gehen wir jetzt mal von aus wir machen das jetzt ja mal mit dem chatter wir nehmen jetzt einfach hier result
ok das ist das andere result
result
string
ok so und hier return
machen wir jetzt bail
ok das funst
Hier, Bale. Keine Ahnung. Chatter
not found. Okay, das reicht.
So.
Let
chatter
await. What?
Was macht das?
Kann ich jetzt so sagen?
Ah, jetzt kriege ich hier den
Error.
Aber so richtig
So richtig verstehen tue ich es noch nicht, was jetzt der Vorteil ist davon, Anyhow zu verwenden.
Ich hätte gedacht, man sieht jetzt irgendwie so schön, wie das, man sieht jetzt hier irgendwie, wenn mehrere Errors geschachtelt sind oder so vielleicht.
Kann ich jetzt hier sagen, Context?
Context? With Context?
Context?
Äh, keine Ahnung, Run?
Und jetzt Fragezeichen?
Hä?
Ja, wo ist denn da jetzt der Sinn?
Das kippt auch nicht mehr aus.
Oder ist einfach hier
mein Tracing Error zu dumm dafür,
die Sachen anzuzeigen.
Oh, Missing Attribute Omega, lul.
Ja.
Aber warum bailt der denn?
Ah, okay, weil es kein Error gegeben hat.
Aber jetzt steht hier Error run und nicht...
Hier sollte...
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, hier kommt Chatter not found und run zusammen dann.
Hä?
Ja, und was bringt mir jetzt das mit dem Kontext?
Hm.
Also ich sehe jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch nicht den großen Vorteil gegenüber dem Standard-Error-Kram.
Kannst den Error weiter anreichern mit mehr Kontext?
Ja, schön und gut.
Also ich kann jetzt hier sagen, Error, Kontext, 0w.
Ja, alles schön und gut.
Aber ich kann das nicht richtig printen, ne?
Guck, das zeigt immer nur den Letzten an.
Ich glaube, das Tracing-Ding ist einfach zu dumm dafür.
Das richtig anzuzeigen.
Was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt hier sage, Format?
Äh, Format?
Was? Du musst halt den Typen nicht angeben und das konfrontiert dir die Errors automatisch.
Aber ich sehe jetzt wirklich auch gerade keinen Unterschied zu dem normalen Error-Kram.
Kann ich das vielleicht so machen?
Geht nicht. Weil?
Hormat must be a string literal.
Ist es doch.
Oh, string literal.
Hä?
Ist das dumm?
Ha?
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist das jetzt anscheinend besser.
Okay, so, hier, zack.
Und jetzt Error.
Error.
Äh, B.
Und das bringt jetzt was?
immer noch nichts.
Also ich checke
wirklich nicht den Vorteil
davon jetzt gerade.
Das ist mir jetzt nicht ganz
einleuchtend.
Ja, ist ja alles schön
mit Kontext und so.
Also, irgendwie
check ich überhaupt nicht,
wofür das
gut sein soll.
Okay.
Why use Rust
anyhow? Gibt's da irgendwie...
Okay, erklär mal.
Erklärt mal,
Warum? Warum?
Oh, cut. Medium.
Gehen wir nicht auf den Sack.
Creating and returning errors. Ja.
Das geht aber... Bis jetzt sehe ich da noch wenig Vorteil
gegenüber dem normalen.
Ja, shouldn't use it.
Ja, aber das geht mit normalen
Errors doch auch.
Ah, Moment. Ne, mit normalen
Errors geht das nicht. Das geht mit
Results, aber nicht mit Errors.
Ach so.
Oh.
Okay.
Ich kann jetzt aber nicht sagen, dass ich es verstanden habe.
Aber was bringt mir das denn, das Kontext
adden, wenn ich das überhaupt nicht richtig printen kann?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe immer nur...
Anyhow
Tokyo Tracing
print.
How can I print
trace that collect by Anyhow?
Ja.
Geht das vielleicht nicht?
You have to make a new wrapper for Anyhow Error
and implement intoResponse.
What the fuck? IntoResponse?
Und, und...
Also das ist mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt alles ein bisschen hoch.
Also ich verstehe überhaupt nicht
Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht den Sinn davon
Ehrlich gesagt
Was
Ich check es wirklich nicht
Was ist der Vorteil gegenüber
Einfach dem Standard Error Type
Ich sehe es nicht
Keine Ahnung
Vielleicht muss ich einfach mal größere
Rust Projekte oder so machen
dass ich das feststelle, dass das irgendwie auf den Sack geht.
Keine Ahnung.
Man fühlt sich high IQ.
Current Output.
Moment. Warum ist das der Current Output?
Das will ich auch haben.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wir machen jetzt einfach mal
Print.
Einfach nur Printline.
Printline B.
Zack.
Geht natürlich nicht. Warum?
Must be a string literal.
Format.
Aber, aber, aber, aber wie, wie...
Wie kann ich das printen?
So, printen wir das
Printen wir das
Die Debug-Ausgabe vom Error
Geht immer noch nicht
Argument is never
Achso, Moment, Moment, Moment
Ich hab ja auch hier falsch
Alter, warum geht denn mein Format nicht?
Was mach ich denn hier falsch?
Hä? Was mache ich denn hier falsch?
Warum kann ich nicht Format Printline machen?
Ach, Printline macht das schon.
Aha.
Also quasi sowas hier.
Bam.
Ach, gucke mal.
Das geht.
Dann printet er diesen ganzen Krempel.
Okay.
Jetzt sehe ich den Vorteil davon.
Du kannst jetzt beispielsweise,
wenn hier ein Error geworfen wird,
kannst du hier noch Infos
attachen dazu und dann am Ende
dieses ganze Ding printen.
Okay, macht Sinn.
Macht Sinn.
Aber wenn das mit Println
geht, dann geht das doch auch mit
Tracing
Error.
So, oder?
Tracing Error. Das müsste doch so auch funktionieren.
jetzt wird ein bisschen viel ja geht doch geht doch hätte ich einfach mal
gleich richtig gemacht
geht doch so wenn es okay ist okay dann sagt da erkenne ich jetzt tatsächlich
den vorteil du siehst du die einzelnen kontext sachen untereinander und kannst
du noch ein bisschen was dran attention ok macht sinn leuchtet mir ein passt
Geht leuchtet ein.
Passt. Alles gut.
So, und was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen,
weil ihr gesagt habt, die coolen Leute,
Die coolen Leute benutzen nicht Anyhow, sondern Irie.
Was ist denn an Irie so viel geiler?
Use? Okay, Details.
Chatge, bevor ich mir das jetzt angucke,
Sag mir mal, warum das viel geiler ist.
Das sieht für mich genauso aus, ehrlich gesagt.
Ist die Fehlermeldung dann schöner?
Oder wie?
Ist die besser formatiert, oder was?
Okay, aber das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut so.
Ich fehlermelde mich schöner formatiert.
Okay.
Was macht denn das hier jetzt dann im Vergleich?
Ah, okay, das macht nur den letzten.
Und die Debug-Ausgabe
printet quasi alles.
Okay, sinnvoll.
Das hier
finde ich ehrlich gesagt ganz praktisch.
Also im Prinzip ist Irie wie Anyhow
nur mit schönerer Ausgabe, oder was?
Okay, ich glaube,
ich glaube da kann ich da kann ich darauf verzichten das brauche erstmal
nicht okay jetzt haben wir uns ein bisschen mit error handling beschäftigt
so richtig so richtig durchblicken tun noch nicht aber ich würde sagen jetzt
versuchen wir was von unserem usb device auszulesen und da fangen da fallen
garantiert auch irgendwelche
Errors bei auf, die man handeln
muss. Also machen wir
diesen ganzen Krempel hier mit Chatter wieder weg.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Ich behalte mir mal vor, da in Zukunft
noch einen Stream drüber zu machen, wenn ich
besser durchblicke.
Also, machen wir das mal weg.
So, hier. USB
Device. Das haben wir.
Wir wollen jetzt was lesen von unserem USB
Device.
Kundenconvert.
Okay, warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Vorher ging das.
Vorher ging das, Chatge.
Mit meinem alten Error-Type ging das.
Warum geht...
Okay, ne?
Vorher hatte ich den Error-Type hier.
Vorher hatte ich den Error-Type und das ging.
Warum geht das
mit dem
Anyhow Error Type nicht?
Er sagt
Din SCD
Error Size is not
certified
Da kann man doch bestimmt hier sagen
Plus Size oder irgendwie sowas
Ne, Size
Keine Ahnung
Plus Size
das heißt irgendwie so konnte man noch dran schreiben keine ahnung keine ahnung bad why
anyhow rust not size google wird es wissen wenn ich weiß es die ki
die kfd kate muss das recht leute er noch sei es
Naja.
Nicht wirklich.
Ach so.
Ähm.
Dann benutze ich hier doch eigentlich den falschen, oder?
Da muss ich hier auch den Anyhow-Error benutzen.
Also quasi use Anyhow.
Error.
Oder auch nicht.
Hä?
Du musst den Error-Typ nicht angeben.
Ah.
Okay.
Aber nicht Error.
Ich bin ja auch dumm.
Warte mal.
Result.
Okay.
Da muss ich halt wirklich use.
Anyhow.
Woher hab ich das eigentlich?
ich das standard die die resulte drin und jetzt selbst ja ok ok dass das
funks aber nicht guck mal not convert error type und stritt to error
Also am Standard-Error-Typ hat das funktioniert.
Das ist doch nicht so geil, hm?
Der Google-Kai ist wieder zu dumm.
Ja, das kenne ich, ja.
Sondern Kontext.
Okay, der KI ist zu dumm.
Also ich soll nicht
okay or machen,
sondern Kontext benutzen.
Okay, Punkt Kontext.
So.
Ach, jetzt funzt das.
okay okay gibt irgendwas inkompatibles zurück also im prinzip hier auch im
prinzip hier auch kontext kann kann kontext auch direkt format ohne dass ich
es muss
Ist ja doof.
Aha, also jetzt
funzt das.
USB-Device.
Okay, zack, öffnen wir mal.
Das USB-Device geht.
So, dann versuchen wir mal was zu lesen von dem USB-Device.
Da muss ich jetzt mal
in mich gehen.
Die ganzen Klempel hier weg.
Random kann auch weg.
Direction.
Okay.
Also, ich will jetzt von meinem USB-Device
Async was lesen.
Also, wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit?
Machen wir hier eine Function.
Async Function Read
USB-Device. Okay.
So.
Der kriegt
ein USB-Device.
Ich meine, das könnten wir eigentlich als
Funktion im USB-Device machen, aber
Wie wirst du denn an die Parameter für die OpenUSB Funktion bekommen?
Ganz einfach, ich habe gesagt, lsusb oder auch nicht, apt install lsusb, apt install
command not found, yes.
Yes.
Wenn ich jetzt Glück habe,
zeig dir mir das gleich an.
Okay, ich bin zu dumm für Command Not Found.
USB-Utils
oder sowas.
Upt-Search
USB-Utils.
Irgendwie sowas vielleicht.
Upt-Install.
USB-Utils
wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
LS-USB.
Da bin ich dran gekommen.
guck mal 0 fcf 1008 ls usb man muss um das usb die war auf das usb device zugreifen zu können
brauchst du eine vendor id und eine product id und die habe ich einfach ausgelesen das gute ist es
gibt glaube ich nur drei sticks auf der ganzen welt nämlich irgendwie es gibt
diesen dünner dünner stream stick und zwei von garmin glaube ich mehr sticks
gibt es nicht also hier könnte man die id ist eigentlich hart korn und es
funktioniert so okay jetzt jetzt versuchen wir was vom usb device
Async
Fn, hier read
from
USB
Fuck
Richtig schreiben, Async
Wir returnen hier mal, ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher
returnen hier mal ein Result
Also
Wir wollen hier
Okay
Wir übernehmen
jetzt mal hier, nehmen wir mal ein Device
USB Device
und jetzt übergeben wir das.
Read from USB
await.
Zack.
Okay, wunderbar.
Does not need to be mutable.
Auch gut.
So, jetzt können wir das hier
mal ausprobieren. Also, wir gehen
jetzt hier auf Device.
Ah,
sehr schlau von mir, Max.
High IQ.
Die Dinger sind nicht public.
Also, wir gehen jetzt mal auf unser USB-Device und sagen EPIN.
Ich glaube, es ist immer verkehrt rum.
Input ist quasi Lesen vom USB-Device und Output ist, glaube ich, Schreiben.
Das ist quasi von sich vom Haus, nicht vom USB-Device.
Also, EPIN, Reader.
Reader.
Takes one parameter.
Okay, was denn für ein?
Buffer size.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
64.
Expected result.
Zack.
Ne, da geht überhaupt nichts verkehrt.
Ach so, das ist, weil ich das hier nicht angegeben habe.
Deswegen.
So.
Also.
Reader.
Jetzt kommt der Knackpunkt.
Ich hab, ich hab
mich im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen belesen.
Also, mir ist ja vorgeschwebt, sinngemäß, dass man sowas machen kann.
Hier, guck mal.
Vor...
Hallo?
Dass man sowas machen kann hier.
Vor X in.
Dann habe ich aber gelernt...
Dann habe ich aber gelernt, dass...
Rust
keine Async
Iterators hat.
Also in C Sharp
beispielsweise kann man das machen.
In Rust nicht.
Es gibt ein Rust Nightly Feature.
Das ist aber noch komplett unfertig.
So, und dann habe ich mir mal
angeguckt, was kann man denn sonst machen,
damit man sowas
ähnliches machen kann.
Weil ich brauche ja zwei Arten von dem USB-Gerät lesen und schreiben. Ich brauche einmal ein kontinuierliches Lesen für die Broadcast-Messages, also das, was reinkommt, wenn es dann die Sensoren überwacht.
und einmal so ein Ding mit Timeout, so nach dem Motto, ich schicke einen Befehl an das USB-Gerät
und dann warte ich für, sagen wir mal, eine Sekunde, wenn die richtige Antwort kommt, ist okay,
wenn nicht, breche ich ab.
So, das heißt, wir machen jetzt erstmal sowas wie kontinuierliches, kontinuierliches.
Neben dem Channel, das Dumme, das habe ich mir auch gedacht, das Dumme an einem Channel ist,
dass der nur funktioniert
mit
mit einem extra Background-Task.
Und das muss doch irgendwie auch anders gehen.
Und da habe ich was gefunden.
Da habe ich, was weiß ich, Rust
Stream Unfold.
Das hat mir, by the way, ChatGPT
gesagt, ja. Also man kann hier wohl
sowas machen.
Futures Stream
Unfold
und dann daraus
irgendwie eine Schleife bauen.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ich habe legit keinen Plus Chimmer.
Wir probieren das hier einfach aus.
Zack.
Stream gibt es schon mal nicht. Nice. Import.
Bam.
Ja, das geht auch.
Aber ist dein Ding ein Stream?
Naja, das sind kontinuierliche Bytes, die vom USB-Device kommen, die gepasst werden und dann zu einer Message irgendwann werden.
Schauen wir mal.
Wie funktioniert...
Jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken.
Wie funktioniert denn dieser Krempel hier überhaupt?
Ja, aber vom Typ her, wie?
Keine Ahnung.
Was meinst du?
Aber mit dem Channel habe ich das Problem
Wie sage ich
im Channel zum Beispiel
dass er terminaten soll
Das geht
Es sei denn
man kann sagen, wenn der Endpunkt
closed wird, dann
Okay, dann probieren wir das
Wir probieren das mal kurz mit dem Channel
Channel klingt mir nämlich deutlich sympathischer.
Wir faken das einfach mal kurz, okay?
Wir tun mal so, als ob.
Wir faken das mal kurz.
Also, read from USB-Device.
Perfekt.
Wir faken das jetzt mal kurz.
Also, wir brauchen einen Channel.
Das ist ein Tokio...
Äh...
Channel?
Tokio Channels.
Channels.
MPS will ich haben.
Multi-Producer-Single-Consumer.
Gibt's nicht.
Gibt's dafür ein Example vielleicht?
Tokio MPS
Example.
Ist auch geil.
Gibt es kein Example für. Sehr schön.
Okay, so
fand es das.
Vielleicht habe ich auch das Feature nicht aktuell.
Okay, guck mal. Muss ein Background Thread
starten. Anders geht das nicht.
Und dann hier ein Channel.
Import.
alternativ kann ich auch sagen, Tokio Sync
MPSC, ne?
Channel. Buffer.
Einen. Ich will nur einen
drin haben in meinem Channel.
Eine Message in meinem
Channel, das reicht.
Und dann soll
er erstmal verarbeiten.
Wie ist denn das? Mal angenommen, ich sag jetzt hier
Mal angenommen, ich sag jetzt hier, hey, du kannst
10 Messages da, du kannst 100 Messages da reinschreiben.
Blockt
der Sender,
wenn es voll ist?
Ich hoffe mal.
Okay.
Und jetzt?
Return
Rx.
Okay, machen wir hier, weiß nicht, 10.000.
Wir machen mal irgendwo noch einen Sleep rein.
Machen wir jetzt hier irgendwie, äh,
Tokyo Time Sleep,
siehste, weißt du, aber nicht,
aber nicht from seconds,
from milliseconds.
Ey, das ist, das ist Rust-Stells,
das Doppelpunkt,
Doppelpunkt-Wahnsinn ist das hier.
Wir machen 10 Millisekunden zwischen jeder Zahl.
Ja, meinetwegen.
So, und jetzt kann ich sagen, hier drinnen...
Äh, das geht schon mal nicht.
By the way, das muss dann gar nicht Async sein, ne?
So, und jetzt bekomme ich hier...
Receiver raus.
Ja.
Und da kann ich jetzt was sagen?
Receiver?
Rec await.
Ah, das muss Mut.
Mut muss das sein.
Mut.
Await.
So.
Nein.
Geht schon mal nicht.
Wie iterate ich das denn jetzt?
Eater.
Gibt es sowas?
Excellent.
Nee, oder? Das funktioniert so...
Ich glaube, mit einer Schleife funktioniert das so nicht.
Äh.
Moment.
Jetzt bin ich...
Jetzt bin ich etwas...
verwirrt.
Ich will eine Schleife haben.
Ich lass das jetzt einfach mal so.
Debug?
X. So, das sollte jetzt ja
quasi eine ganze Weile hängen.
Sudo?
Hä?
Das macht gar nichts.
Achso.
Ich hab das hier mit Cologne vergessen.
Lull.
Ey, da kommt nur ein Wert
Moment, warum kommt da nur ein Wert?
Ich mach doch ne Schleife da drüber
Ach, ne
Ah, ich glaub ich weiß woran es liegt
Ich glaube
ETF
Die Idee macht ein komisches Ding
Ich glaube das muss man anders machen
Da muss man so ne Wildschleife draus machen
Da musst du sagen, hier while
While
Da war es doch schon, das war genau so was
Genau richtig
Was die KI gerade vorgeschlagen hat
While
Das da, das muss man machen, genau
Next gibt es nicht
Äh, okay
Äh, warum
Warum
Warum gibt es next nicht
Next
The method next exists for struct, but its trade bounds were not satisfied.
Method cannot be called to unsatisfy trade bounds.
The stream type must be unpin.
Muss ich das so machen?
Pin?
Ey, kein Plassen.
Schimmer.
Nee.
Okay.
Keine Ahnung.
Wie man hier
Warum geht das nicht?
Also so einfach, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
So, wir haben doch hier
Let some receiver await.
Ja, wieso? Okay, genau so
mache ich das doch.
Du musst es importieren.
Receiver.
Hä?
Chat, was ist jetzt anders?
Man muss Receive machen anstatt Next.
Okay, Five Head.
Okay.
Und jetzt haben wir hier...
...quasi einen unendlichen...
...nahezu unendlichen Stream davon.
Aber...
Okay, schön und gut.
Schön und gut, ja.
Wie kriegt er denn jetzt?
Mal angenommen...
Wartet mal. Mal angenommen, ich sag jetzt hier
Break.
Das will ich mal ausprobieren.
Kriege ich dann, wenn ein Receiver
droppt? Wir machen mal hier
Tokyo Sleep
eine Sekunde.
Nee.
Achso, ich muss den ja auch noch droppen.
Drop.
Ja, also wenn der out of scope geht...
Ah ja, okay.
Das heißt, wenn der out of scope geht, dann hört auch die Schleife hier drinnen auf zu producen.
Okay, ganz ehrlich, das mit dem Channel klingt gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ich starte jetzt zwar einen Background Thread, aber wen juckt's?
Ist ja nicht so, als hätten wir hier irgendwie große Beschränkungen auf dem Rechner.
So, und jetzt lesen wir was von unserem USB-Gerät.
Jetzt lesen wir was von unserem USB-Gerät.
So, also.
Wie schreibt man? So schreibt man da was rein.
Das muss ich mir behalten.
Also, Loop.
Zack.
Das ist zum Abbrechen. Das ist wichtig.
Also, Loop.
So, Device.
Reader.
Ne.
Endpoint in.
Reader.
64.
Ah, Moment, weil das das Captured gibt es jetzt Probleme, ne?
Value used after being moved.
Das ist jetzt Rust-Gedöns.
Das heißt, ich will hier eigentlich nur eine Referenz.
Glaube ich, dass ich nur eine Referenz will.
Und nur eine Referenz.
In der Hoffnung, das gibt keine Probleme.
Borrowed Data Escapes.
Ja, das habe ich mir gedacht, dass das nicht funktioniert.
So, weil
das jetzt hier aus dem Scope gehen kann.
Das heißt, was muss ich jetzt
machen?
Oh, Rust-Logik, alle.
Was muss ich jetzt machen?
Dass das hier alive bleibt.
Siehst du, da geht es jetzt schon los.
Okay, können wir nicht sagen...
Nochmal so, ob das theoretisch funktioniert.
Können wir nicht sagen...
Wir machen den Reader...
Wir machen den Reader hier.
Das geht jetzt, oder?
Weil
Weil jetzt wird er nicht mehrfach gemovt
Jetzt, jetzt funktioniert das
Okay, jetzt haben wir hier den Reader
Aber, jetzt haben wir wieder das, was ich euch versucht habe
Vorher zu zeigen
Der nächste Aufruf, der geht nicht, weil das hier schon gemovt wurde
Ja
So.
Gucken wir mal.
Versuchen wir jetzt erstmal was von unserem USB-Device zu lesen.
Also, Reader.
So, wir lesen jetzt mal irgendwas.
Reader.
Read.
Read Buff.
Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall die Tokio-Variante.
Okay, da brauchen wir einen Buffer.
Was denn für einen?
Äh, Let.
Irgendwie ein Array oder so?
Moment.
Ist das die falsche Synth?
Ist das vielleicht 512U8?
Hm.
Gut.
Ich hab das doch richtig gemacht.
Ach, das ist der Typ.
Das ist der Typ.
Also so muss ich da machen.
Was ist, wenn ich das leere?
Komm, wir nehmen Vector, oder? Vector ist doch viel, viel sinniger. Nehmen wir hier Buff gleich.
Vector.
New.
Und den nehmen wir jetzt als Buffer. Mutt muss der noch sein. Mutt.
Oder auch nicht. Reader? Cannot borrow immutable reader as mutable. Okay.
Wollen wir jetzt den Reader? Mutt.
Buffer. Gibt's nicht.
Und?
Achso, muss ich sagen, dass ich den als Vektor U8 haben will.
Okay.
Und jetzt, await.
So, also, was machen wir jetzt?
Ich lupe jetzt
Den Buffer packen wir mal hier mit rein
In die Schleife, dass wir den immer neu haben
So, ich lupe jetzt
Über
Also unendlich lange mit meinem USB Device
Und lass davon was lesen
Sollte ich einen Fehler haben beim Lesen
Ja was mache ich denn dann
Da muss ich erstmal gucken was das für ein Fehler ist
Du hattest den Typen hinter dem Gleich statt hinter dem Doppelpunkt.
Bei der U8-Geschichte, ne?
Ja.
So, also so will ich ja auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ich will ja nicht bei jedem Fehler irgendwie aussteigen.
Ja, nee, nee.
Ich will, was...
Oh mein Gott, was?
So, hier kann ich schon mal bei Tokyo spawnen.
In dem Fall kriege ich schon mal keinen Return-Wert zurück.
Ist das schlimm?
Nö.
Also, wie mache ich das denn jetzt hier?
Wait, wahrscheinlich muss ich das matchen.
Also.
Wenn der Reader sagt, okay.
Dann returnen wir die Bytes
Ach ne
Die Bytes sind ja im Buffer
Äh
Ach die Size die geredet wird
Okay
Äh
Äh wie nennen wir es
Num Bytes Read
So das gehen wir zurück
Wenn es ein Error ist
Was für ein Error ist denn das hier an der Stelle
Es ist ein
Wie kann ich jetzt erkennen
welcher Error-Typ das ist, wenn ich hier drauf klicke, vielleicht.
Das ist
ein...
Das ist kein
Standard-Error, oder? Oder doch?
Das ist ein I.O.-Error.
Das könnte die IDE
aber auch ein bisschen schöner anzeigen. Das ist ein
I.O.-Error.
So, und wie kriege ich jetzt raus,
welchen Error
ich hier bekomme.
Also.
Was wirft denn das Ding für Errors?
Steht da was da?
Also, es
returnt
0 Bytes gelesen, wenn es
EOF ist oder wenn der Buffer nicht
genug Kapazität hat. Okay.
Errors. If this function encounters
Okay.
Ja, aber es gibt ja nur I.O. Error, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also das returnt nur I.O. Errors.
Was gibt es denn?
Was gibt es denn bei I.O. Error für Varianten?
Warte.
WTF?
Rappere?
What?
Was zum Teufel soll Rappere sein?
Rappere?
What?
Moment, ich glaube, es gibt sowas wie
Kind.
Da kann man checken, was das für ein Error ist.
Boah!
Oh, Alter!
Okay, die will ich nicht alle
einzeln handeln.
Will ich da überhaupt
irgendwas extra
handeln?
Not found it. Das brauch ich doch alles nicht.
Network on region not connected. Komm, scheiß drauf.
Wir machen das. Das ist egal.
Wenn es einen Error
beim Reden gibt, dann ist es
ein Fehler.
Fehler heißt Break.
Wir brechen ab zu lesen.
bricht denn auch dann
bricht der Reader ab?
bricht der Reader ab, wenn der letzte Sender
das müssen wir ausprobieren
ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie sich das Zeug
verhält
wir machen jetzt, okay, weißt du was, wir machen jetzt einfach
hier einen Break rein, okay, Break
Bam, Break
Die Frage ist, bricht diese Schleife hier ab?
Anscheinend.
Oh mein Gott, ich habe auch hier einen Break.
Das ist doch Blödsinn.
Debug.
Wir können auch ein Debug Breakpoint setzen
Aber so advanced zu sagen haben wir nicht
Okay, die Schleife bricht ab
Also
Wenn
Wenn hier
Der
Wenn es keinen Sender mehr gibt
Hä?
Moment, Moment, Moment
Moment.
Wir machen mal kurz eine Endlosschleife.
Okay, jetzt blicke ich nicht durch.
Also das ist okay.
Jetzt bleibt er hier drinnen hängen.
Okay.
Ah, okay.
Der erkennt, dass der noch eine Referenz auf TX hat.
Also ich glaube, sobald das letzte TX aus dem Scope geht...
Mit welchem Programm debuggt man eigentlich ein Rust-Programm?
Keine Ahnung, mit dem eingebauten Debugger von Rust-Strober.
Ich weiß nicht, auf was der basiert.
So.
Okay, also das funktioniert schon mal.
Da bin ich zufrieden mit.
Das heißt, wenn das hier breakt...
Michael50Billian, schön, dass du am Start bist.
Und by the way, Leute,
danke schön, Michael, für deinen Sub.
By the way, Leute, wenn euch der Stream gefällt,
könnt ihr mir an der Stelle einen Follow dalassen.
Freut mich immer sehr, wenn ich sehe,
dass euch gefällt und dass
mehr Leute
immer am Start sind.
Freut mich fast so sehr wie
einen Subscription.
Und ihr kriegt auch
Notifikation, ihr könnt übrigens die Notification
Sachen ausschalten bei Twitch, ne, wenn ihr sagt,
ab und zu will ich bei Max mal gucken, aber keinen
Bock rumgespamme, einfach nicht
anmachen. Ich hab bei vielen Channels auch
keine Glocke an und sowas.
Ich find dieses, bitte schön, hier mit
Glocke und so, für'n Arsch.
Ich hab, glaub ich, auch nur bei
drei Channels die Notifications an.
Es freut mich, dass
ihr am Start seid und auch bei
Rust mitguckt, was
jetzt ja wirklich nicht jedermanns Sache ist.
Das stimmt. So selten wie ich on bin.
Das stimmt auch. Macht die Glocke an.
Der Michael hat recht, Leute. Macht die Glocke an.
Ich bin eh in letzter Zeit so selten on.
Dann ist wichtig, dass ihr mitklickt, dass ich online bin.
Also jetzt followen und direkt Glocke anmachen.
Oder followen ohne Glocke anmachen. Hauptsache followen.
Also das passt schon mal. Das finde ich ganz gut.
Das heißt, wenn das hier oben...
...hier breakt, weil es einen Error gibt,
dann geht er auch hier aus der Schleife raus.
Das ist okay.
Das finde ich okay.
Okay.
Also.
Weiter im Text.
Wir lesen jetzt
vom USB-Gerät.
So, im Endeffekt ist es immer noch Endlosschleife, ne?
Jaja.
Das hängt jetzt.
Weil der ja noch nicht fertig ist mit dem Channel.
Okay.
So, jetzt müssen wir ein bisschen mehr machen.
Also, wenn das hier...
Wir müssen gerade noch was anderes checken.
Also, ReadFromUSB ist ja schön und gut.
Aber wie kann ich jetzt sagen,
Ich will einen Timeout.
Gibt es sowas wie hier?
Timeout?
Oder gibt es da nur dieses Tokyo Duration Timeout?
Tokyo.
Time.
Timeout.
Das kann man ja so machen.
Aber da weiß ich nicht, wie ich das in der Schleife gescheit einbinden soll.
Du meinst Read?
Ne, da kann ich einfach Set Timeout machen.
Ich würde allgemein sagen
Wenn der für 10 Sekunden
Keine Messages zurück
Kein Retimer
Wenn der für 10 Sekunden keine Messages zurückgeliefert hat
Dann
Will ich abbrechen
Ja
Hab ich gesehen
Ja.
Es hat, ich gebe dir recht,
es hat nicht nach RTS ausgesehen.
Aber StarCraft, das wird
ein RTS. Ansonsten kann ich mir nicht anders
erklären. Es macht eigentlich
wenig Sinn.
Aber wenn es ein RTS wäre, hätten sie vielleicht
StarCraft 3 genannt.
Aber ich habe nur gesagt, StarCraft
will return. Also, keine Ahnung.
Also, ich will
das abbrechen?
Warte mal, lass uns mal checken. Also wir könnten sagen,
Tokio.
Time?
Time out.
Open World Shooter.
Starcraft Style. Okay.
Äh.
Wo ist das Problem jetzt?
Wie, du kannst das nicht finden in dem Scope?
Willst du mich veräppeln?
Willst du mich verarschen?
Hä?
Muss ich da vielleicht noch Features bei Tokio aktivieren, die ich nicht aktiviert habe?
Nicht aktiviert habe?
Tokio, Tokio, Tokio.
Pull.
Und Sync.
Nö, pass.
Hä?
Was?
Was hat mein Rust wieder für Probleme?
Tokio?
Time?
Timeout?
Ach, es ist
Timeout mit kleinem T.
WTF, Alter.
Timeout und jetzt Duration.
Duration.
From seconds 5 ist okay.
Receiver.
Reck.
Ne, so geil ist das jetzt nicht.
So, jetzt kann ich das verteil-mauten.
Ist ja schön und gut.
Aber.
Wenn ich das jetzt erwarte.
Dann.
Dann ist das ja nur ein Result.
Und das kann ich nur einmal erwarten.
Wie macht man da jetzt einen Schleifer draus?
Halt jedes Mal wieder mit.
Aber schleift das jetzt wirklich?
Dann auch so?
Nee, das macht kein...
Das läuft einmal oder so, ne?
Muss ich...
Ich muss das hier reinpacken, ne?
Ich muss das hier reinpacken.
Muss das hier reinpacken.
und jetzt sage ich sum
expected result
option, also sage ich
jetzt quasi okay
sum i
jetzt, und jetzt schleift es, ne
jetzt schleift es, sehr gut
es schleift, Leute
so, und jetzt sollte
das Ding aber
nach 5 Sekunden, machen wir mal eine Sekunde
okay, jetzt sollte das Ding aber nach einer
Sekunde timeouten
macht's auch
Excellent.
Also das heißt, wenn wir für eine Sekunde lang keine Nachricht bekommen haben, timeouten wir.
Ja, so ist das doch eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Du-du-du.
So, sagen wir, wir gucken, kommt für eine Sekunde, kommt keine Message rein, weg damit.
Das ist schon mal gut.
So.
Jetzt ja das Ding.
Wir haben immer noch das Problem hier
mit dem USB-Device.
Das USB-Device muss eine Referenz sein.
Aber
dann funzt das nicht.
Muss ich das vielleicht irgendwie vorher
nochmal irgendwie was zuweisen?
device hier so in der funktion oder so wieso das ist jetzt rust magic da bin
ich jetzt etwas überfragt macht und sich hier der vielleicht ein trainer
verhalten? Ne.
Das geht nicht wegen dem Move.
Ja, ist egal, ob mit
oder ohne Move.
Brauch ich... Okay, das ist
Multithreading. Brauch ich da jetzt
ein Arc drumherum? Oder sowas?
Dass das funktioniert?
Let dev gleich arg?
Wie weiß?
Ne.
Könntest du aber, kannst du dem...
Geht das so?
Nee.
Okay.
Kein Schimmer, aber...
KI regelt das schon.
Das ist das Hauptproblem.
Wenn ein USB-Device geklont werden kann, kann es das?
Also aus irgendwelchen Gründen kann man es klonen, aber...
So sinnvoll ist es jetzt irgendwie nicht.
Use an Arc, das sag ich doch.
Arc muss man schon hier vorher machen.
Sag ich doch, dass man ein Arc benutzen soll.
Da lag ich doch schon mal gar nicht so falsch.
Siehste?
Da lag ich schon mal gar nicht so falsch.
Cannot move out of Arc.
heißt ich brauche noch einen muttext drumherum oder wie weil multithreading theoretisch ich
brauche nur text rum oder glaube ich mal also alleine reicht nicht warum nicht cannot move
out of arc.
Das ist wegen dem Reader, hä?
Das heißt, ich brauche
eigentlich einen Arc...
Ach du Scheiße, Alter.
Einen Arc Mutex
of USB Device.
So, oder?
Weil Ark alleine reicht ja nicht.
Äh.
Okay, ich bin gerade ein wenig verwirrt.
Ey, was muss ich jetzt machen?
Device? Lock, oder?
Lock
Let
Device
Lock
Und jetzt kann ich
Immer noch nicht
Achso
Das kann ja fehlen.
Was mache ich denn, wenn das
fehlt?
Wenn das fehlt?
Okay, bin ich mir jetzt
nicht sicher, ob das so richtig ist,
was ich da mache.
Und wenn es fehlt,
dann
return ich einfach.
Kann ich hier nichts machen. Was?
Ah! Rust!
Future cannot be sent between threats
safely.
Okay, ich sehe schon.
Das ist deutlich komplizierter mal wieder,
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ist das jetzt nicht komplett pipi?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wie ich es sonst machen soll.
Also, ein reiner Arc tut es anscheinend nicht.
Tja.
Da hören jetzt meine Rust-Skills auf.
Moved er das hier irgendwie anders?
Vielleicht?
Nee, den Move brauchen wir.
Jepp!
Alter, laber nicht!
Das ist der Fehler auf dein Kram, ey.
Was?
Das macht doch keinen Sinn.
Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das labert einfach nur wieder dummes Zeug.
Okay, ich hab, ich hab, Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Kann ich vielleicht in Ark eine Referenz von...
Also ich glaube, ich glaube, das mit dem Mutex war prinzipiell schon nicht verkehrt.
Ich glaube, das mit dem Mutex war schon nicht verkehrt.
Jetzt.
Jetzt Mut.
Geht nicht.
Äh.
Jetzt Mut.
What the f...
Fuck.
Kannst du der Funktion nicht einfach nur den Reader geben bei Value?
Da geht der Reader aber auch out of scope.
Wenn ich der Funktion den Reader gebe.
Okay, ich habe legit keinen Plastenschimmer, was ich machen soll.
Ich muss das locken.
Was soll ich sagen? Device, Lock.
Bam. So.
Das geht nicht anders.
Unwrap. Machen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Okay, unwrap.
At device gleich device unwrap.
So, und jetzt muss ich sagen,
hier device.
So, und jetzt will er
Future cannot be sent between threads safely.
Alter, was willst du von mir, Rust?
Future is not sent.
Jawoll, Leute.
Alles klar.
Ey, wenn Future not sent ist, was willst du da machen, ne?
Keine Chance, wenn es nicht sent ist.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was jetzt der Unterschied ist.
das liegt bestimmt daran,
weil das hier den
Mutex capturt
und das irgendeine Referenz intern
wieder auf, das bestimmt
das Problem. Warte mal,
das, das, das, das,
als KI zu fragen.
Und Mutex Guard ist ein Send.
Der immediate Fix. Na dann.
What?
Alter!
Chat-GPT, du bist so useless shit, man!
Ich muss mich hier unbedingt einloggen,
dass man gescheite KI verwenden kann.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Leute, ich hab legit kein
Plassenchimmer, was wir
da jetzt am besten machen.
Aber
Ich muss jetzt auch unbedingt Abendessen
Und dann noch ein bisschen
Guck noch ein bisschen Serie
Bevor ich pennen gehe
Wir machen nächstes Mal weiter
Ich hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen
Und
Was für Serie
Weiß ich auch nicht
Keine Ahnung
Vielleicht
Irgendwas beruhigendes auf jeden Fall
Keine Ahnung
Weiß ich auch nicht
Chat
Keine Ahnung
Hast du das Buch schon gelesen?
Nee.
Gut, Chat-Gip.
Ich esse jetzt was,
dann gehe ich noch ein bisschen Fernsehen gucken.
Bis vielleicht morgen.
Schauen wir mal.
Macht's gut.
See you.